[Music]
I remember growing up I was convinced I
traveled the world just meet these
mind-blowing people connect Jesus you're
like 11 19 in like three weeks are you
jaded yet
he jaded shut up
I feel like my sister is that it yeah no
but we're more like really good friends
yeah but he's tired nights at our good
boys
I was with Cole Cole is not voids I know
she can be like a mess but I don't
really have any other friends you gotta
fly off the dramatic Danger this is
actually a dance costume sporting some
serious cleavage
what's always so much extra stuff
your ex is gonna kill me I want to chill
he won
what's going on that's am I going away
dinner when are you fine tomorrow South
America come on
[Music]
probably just want to get to bed he
wasn't here for a drive
can I come
[Music]
walking to your door
[Music]
trust me I'll meet someone
[Music]
it's a beautiful boy
what are the odds we'll both be arriving
right now I'm a bitter old man these
days shut up
[Music]
happy because for me Life Flowers
one feeling
[Music]